[Música]
dos iglesias 500 habitantes y al final
de la calle principal una institución de
la región
[Música]
el royal palace tercer cabaret más
grande de francia después del moulin
rouge y el nido en parís pero cómo
explicar semejante éxito en un pueblo
remoto de alsacia
[Música]
la razón principal es pierre meyer el
jefe del establecimiento desde hace más
de 40 años
al ojo de parchís
empezamos con 1200 metros cuadrados y
ahora tenemos más de 8.000 metros
cuadrados
[Música]
hoy aquí hay fuego con bríos y un cisne
hielo que yo es culpable
al principio piar me ayer era cocinero
en el restaurante con pista de baile que
tenían sus padres aquí estoy todavía
como cocinero con mi madre hacíamos
buffet al estilo campesino carne asada
pero la cereza del pastel era la banda
con el pequeño espectáculo ya montado
que yo había comprado con seis o siete
bailarinas que venían de parís
un golpe maestro que lo cambiaría todo
en 1980 el programa anunciaba la noche
final con bailarinas provenientes de
parís el restaurante se llenaba
anunciábamos el espectáculo y siempre
después de eso todo el mundo hacía una
reserva era algo nuevo en la región
con una o una el final ahora llegan más
de 200.000 espectadores al año
para el versalles verdad puedes
acompañar a louis freeh a su lugar 4
personas
el jefe insiste en recibir en persona a
los visitantes cada noche
pasen por aquí disfruten de la noche
damas y caballeros cuando veo llegar a
tantas personas todos los días me
pregunto pero de dónde viene toda esta
gente
con el tiempo la popularidad del cabaret
ha logrado atraer a las mejores
bailarinas de todas partes del mundo
no
[Música]
a la es bailarina de revista desde hace
10 años en el cabaret vive a unos 15
kilómetros con su hijo david y su
compañero el también bailarín en el
royal palace
su casa está en medio del campo y no
cambiarían su cotidianidad por nada del
mundo
esto es lo que nos gusta tanto este
pueblo perdido la vista aquí es hermosa
y nos parece un lugar magnífico el
bosque su encanto las vacas
sus jornadas suelen ser bastante
ocupadas porque además de su trabajo
como bailarina en la royal palace a la
también da clases de danza modernas
[Música]
trata de no doblar las rodillas es así
la mayoría de esos estudiantes son niñas
jóvenes que admiran a su maestra
[Música]
me parece muy elegante se mueve muy bien
como una verdadera bailarina es tan
hermoso que me han dado ganas de tomar
clases también
a parte de los artistas los 90 empleados
del cabaret son locales de la región
hoy tiffany touch va a trabajar 18 horas
seguidas hay dos espectáculos en el
programa lo que significa dos servicios
de comidas
es un día muy largo pero la verdad el
tiempo pasa volando sobre todo cuando
hay tantas personas y ahora es temporada
alta
los días de espectáculo la población de
kiwi le se triplica y pasa de 500 a
1.500 personas
tiffany ya empezó su primer turno al
galope
cuántos kilómetros camina en un día
contando a ambos turnos 40 una maratón
uno de cada tres clientes es alemán
en la mesa los comensales están
satisfechos
está bueno si está perfecto
es una terrina de pozo con foie gras
después de la comida crece la
expectativa los clientes toman asiento y
se preparan para la primera presentación
del día
[Música]
el royal palace monta un nuevo
espectáculo cada año todo está calculado
al detalle
[Música]
las bailarinas salen apenas vestidas con
mi niña que es plumas pedrería y un
toque de vanguardia para sorprender al
público
es muy moderno yo me esperaba muchos
frisados pero esto está muy bien
realmente bien
[Música]
el jefe pier mayer es incansable cada
noche vuelve a asistir al espectáculo de
su vida recordando una época del pequeño
restaurante familiar con una pista de
baile sorprendido al ver en lo que se ha
convertido
más